[Musique]
2 co signée par plus de 100 sénateurs et
sénatrices de tout bord politique
témoigne une nouvelle fois de la
capacité de notre assemblée à se saisir
de grands sujets de société solutions
doivent être apportés rapidement et au
delà des clivages politiques
c'est pourquoi nous demandons au
gouvernement d'engager la procédure
accélérée sur ce texte majeur
[Musique]
porter qui a déposé quelques amendements
mais qui ne remettent pas en cause
véritablement le texte issu de
l'assemblée nationale donc grande
satisfaction c'est un pas puisque le
texte sort de l'assemblée nationale
enrichi
voulu réellement alors espérons que ce
sera la dernière étape qui fera qu'enfin
on protégera les enfants on osera dire
les choses et que ça libérera la parole
[Musique]